any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
ryan holliday incomparable ryan holiday
the proprietor of the painted porch
perennial seller
podcast galore that we'll get into
another plosive sounds that i can make
to make my engineer crazy ryan how are
you doing from all the way at bass strap
is it bat strap or bass drop text that's
drop is how i say it but i don't think
it matters that much things are good
here
great it's great to be in touch with you
again we last chatted three or four
years ago and i was
creating my first book and
your company brash check was invaluable
providing help and support that the
traditional publishers are either
unwilling or unknowing to share and i
want to get into that in just a bit
but but i have many of your books here
with me some i only have in digital form
so i've got perennial cellar which is
marked up and annotated properly i've
got uh the daily stoic
i've got uh which i filled out today
very meta orion because i i only use the
morning so there's a morning and evening
portion
uh but i only use the morning portion
for the answer the question the homework
assignment and being a professor i have
to modify and do my own thing
in the in the evening quote unquote
section i fill out what i'm looking
forward to doing today and today i said
i look forward to speaking to the author
of this book on the into the impossible
very much wonderful all right i'm
excited
and then this book which i removed from
my bedroom uh it's a it's a sexual guide
growth hacking um that i keep in the
bedroom and many many other books ego is
the enemy and we're going to get into
all those but first i want to uh commend
you on courage is calling your latest uh
contribution to your ubra and i want to
just commend you on it it's such a such
a delightful book and i think in writing
it i was worried up until the very end
when in the audiobook you read the
audiobook
i was
scared
fearful if you will that there wouldn't
be any self examples there wouldn't be
any work examples how we actually do
that and thankfully you did that at the
very end but i want to start as i often
do
uh with what you're told never to do
which is judging books by their cover so
ryan walk us through the cover the title
why'd you start with this of all the
cardinal virtues and what is that lion
doing on the cover
well of course you should judge a book
by the cover that's why they have covers
uh that is what the job of the cover is
to do it's to catch
people's attention and uh
to symbolize or frame
or uh
evoke the themes or the ideas that the
book is supposed to be about so um when
people say that um i find that it's
either just sort of a reflexive thing
they don't really understand or when i
hear authors say it um that sounds like
an author who's gonna have a real crappy
book with a real bad cover that's not
gonna sell copies so um
what was interesting about this one is
so ego is the enemy uh obstacles away
and stillness is the key we're sort of a
a trilogy there in a box is a trilogy um
this book is roughly the same i think
it's the same size i think we use the
same trim size um but can you hold it up
right into the camera yeah sorry uh
there was uh same trim size same style
actually let me see uh
yes exact same size that's what i mean
um but i wanted to symbolize that this
was
a similar book
in a similar
with a similar approach but thematically
distinct and different
and so
uh that was sort of the the needle to
thread there was how do you make it feel
part of a theme
uh but also make it stand out um
so uh
yeah this is sort of what we settled on
yeah originally it was just the lion
lion is typically what
uh the ancients used to symbolize
courage as far as like an animal spirit
animal if you will um but i felt like it
didn't
the the other like stillness and uh and
obstacle and ego they're they feel very
modern
um
and
uh i wanted something in it that evoked
the classical origins of it or that
evoked the history so that's where the
roman mosaic
going around the edges came from
um
trying to think what else uh
one of the tricky things that that's
that happens as books really start to
work and sort of a tension between
artistic and
uh marketing concerns is like
what should be bigger the title or the
name
right of the author because like you
know
i would think you would want the title
to be biggest because that's what it's
about but if you think about it more
people have heard
of me at this point than have heard of
the title of the book that i just made
up so
um it was sort of a tension between how
big should one be and then how much
other text can you get on there whether
it's a subtitle which i originally
didn't want to do uh but my uk publisher
made a strong argument for doing i also
had to say that this is part of a series
and then evoke the there was just a lot
to get on this cover which you can tell
there's
blurb cover or title subtitle
image name
uh
number one new york times bestseller uh
and then what book
of the pa of my past books was i gonna
mention so there was a lot to there was
a lot to get on this that wasn't on
like uh
the obstacles away has almost nothing on
it i guess is what i would say
and i think you know one one thing i get
from this book you know we talk about
the cardinal virtues and and here in uc
san diego we have a building with the
with the cardinal sins the seven
cardinal sins and their antidotes so
what should you do if you suffer from
gluttony not that that afflicts you uh
you're totally jacked ripped and hench
but i want to know um if if courage is
the first of these cardinal virtues and
i agree with your assertion that without
courage none of the others are possible
but what are the anti-you know
anti-direct anti-podes on the cardinal
compass
so uh i yeah i
started with courage for a couple
reasons number one it typically tends to
be listed first um
it's courage and then uh temperance
justice wisdom that's how i tend to find
it uh rendered sometimes justice and
temperance are flipped sometimes wisdom
is first but in my experience courage is
almost always listed first um
i don't know if that's uh an
alphabetical thing or what
but but courage tends to be listed first
and i think it's the most
timely of the virtues and i would argue
the
the least divisive
slash uh polarizing of the virtues um
every society that has ever existed has
held up
courage as a primary virtue justice we
could have different opinions about what
justice is you know wisdom uh is is is
important to people like you and i but
perhaps not uh you know immediately
sought after by by the entirety of the
population and i couldn't think of a
worse book to start a four book series
with than temperance um so
that was sort of the debate there if i'm
thinking about what the opposites are i
i don't know what i would say
emphatically is the opposite of each
virtue but
as you know aristotle says that all the
virtues exist on a spectrum and that
they're op they don't have one opposite
but two opposites so courage the
opposite of courage is not cowardice the
opposite of courage is cowardice and
recklessness courageness courage is the
midpoint between those two extremes um
and so you know
temperance is the midpoint between too
much and not enough right uh and you
know justice there is let's say
generosity
uh it might be you know a virtue of
justice or let's say honesty too much
honesty and not enough honesty you know
la a a lie of omission is a lie but also
you know uh radical candor might itself
be uh a kind of advice so uh
when when i think about the virtues i
don't just think about them as terms of
what's their opposite but so much as
like what is the right amount of this
trait and how does one apply it
effectively in the right situations
and along those lines you know i kind of
felt uh and and kudos to you for citing
one of the few things aristotle was
right about
almost everything he said about physics
uh was completely wrong you know that
there are not four elements uh in nature
and heavier things don't fall faster
than lighter ones but i agree completely
with that and you make the case also in
the book that love is sort of
concomitant with courage uh but uh it
came to me as sort of as as i listened
to it that the
you know kind of there's a paradox at
work because to be courageous you can't
be courageous if you're not risking
anything like there's no courage you
know for somebody to write a book that
slams president trump i'm sorry that
doesn't take any courage right now on
the other hand uh you know it takes
great courage you know during it to
defend i mean i know how you feel about
trump we're not gonna talk politics we
never talk politics i'm sure uh but uh
but you so you can't have courage
without risk and yet you can't have risk
without there being a possibility of
loss of control and i wonder how does
that mesh with you know this philosophy
of amar fatih
i think i read that as fat eye
but but but tell me how do you mesh this
you know ability to relinquish control
manage risk and then also risk perhaps
much greater things than just keeping
your mouth shut
so the way i think about courage is that
there has to be danger there has to be a
certain amount of uncertainty uh or it's
not courage that's not to say it's not
valuable but if i said hey if you quit
your job um and pursue this other thing
some private venture it will a hundred
percent be uh
uh successful and along the way no one
will doubt you and uh you will be
universally beloved for it from start to
finish of course you should say yes to
this right like why would you say no i
just i just offered you a guarantee but
no one would describe that as a
courageous decision right because there
was no that the outcome was preordained
it was known so to me courage is when
you're putting yourself out there when
you're stepping out under the limb when
you're throwing yourself
the leap into the dark right as they say
and so uh courage to me
is predicated on
uh the fact that you are afraid of it
now i guess we could we could we could
really get semantic about it and go
maybe the outcome is known to everyone
but you but you find it personally scary
for the following reasons now we could
get into that but the point is you have
to be scared of it or courage is not
required or possible so i think that's
step one it's knowing that it's
when we're talking about courage we're
talking about some risk some level of
uncertainty um
i think where it gets uh it gets tricky
is
just because it's risky and you do it
doesn't mean that it's courageous so i
don't just mean uh i i i don't just mean
um
that in in the sense that like uh we're
talking about outcomes i'm
i'm saying um was it the right thing to
do right so
at least in regards to the virtue of
courage or courage as a virtue right um
taking the contrarian view on something
or the opposite view of something might
be courageous if in fact the majority is
wrong right um but but but to simply
let's say courageously put your career
on the line to argue
that the world is flat or that vaccines
don't work or you know or my favorite
conspiracy theory is this one that birds
don't exist uh have you seen this one no
i only like traffic in flat earth yeah
so it's that all birds were destroyed
and now they're like fake it's a
fascinating thing but the point is just
because you're believing in a conspiracy
theory that puts you at odds with polite
society and then you are in there is
real career risk to doing so um that
doesn't make it courageous it just me
you know i get these emails all the time
professor keating einstein was thought
to be a quack crackpot i have this
theory people are calling me a crackpot
by the transposition prince of
transitive
i'll share my nobel prize with you right
right so so courage is ultimately
predicated at least to the stoics on the
pursuit of the right now this is hard to
do we have to take a long historical
view uh and and it gets complicated i
guess the point is a lot of brave
confederate soldiers um
there is something ultimately hollow and
empty about this courage um just as
there is uh emptiness and the courage of
uh someone in the japanese or the german
army in the second world war um because
it was ultimately in pursuit of not just
uh the wrong cause but one of the worst
causes of all time
right yeah and i look at that and i can
combine this kind of risk uh you know
element to courageous as a predicate to
courage and then i see you know humans
as you know so bad at assessing risk you
know compared to like a garter snake you
know like
we sit there and and like i see my
students i always joke about this you
know going to my class they're on their
skateboards of course they're wearing a
mask
they're going downhill they're scrolling
instagram and they're not wearing a
helmet and i'm like you know one of
these things is like much more risky
than some of the other possibilities so
yeah and i wondered you know could we
form like a rubric and and i started to
think about um this concept of entropy
which is like the number of states like
ryan the number of ways i could make
your life twice as good as it is now is
pretty limited like yeah this book is
the best seller you're going to be
number one bestseller the rest of your
career you've got such great content
that you put out around the world i
could double your use youtube
subscribers on the daily stoic channel a
link in the description below and uh and
that would uh that would make you
happier but how many ways could i make
you a thousand times less happy there's
so many more states as physicists would
call it in the face space of of
available um uh you know kind of
outcomes and i think about like yeah i
mean how many ways could could uh could
churchill you describe a great length in
this book who's every single person
every except florence nine gayle does
she have any like skeletons in her
closet or because they almost all even
gandhi i'm gonna get to gandhi later
because he has a mixed record in my book
as well as as churchill etc just
nightingale does she have any like
skeletons in her closet that no one
knows a few yes go ahead okay fine yeah
and it's not important because i think
you know you you should pick and choose
people say like oh don't pick and choose
like it's bad like okay fine so you're
just gonna eat everything on the menu
even though you're allergic to gluten um
but thinking about like how many ways
could something could you use this
concept of entropy like the number of
ways that my life could be worse as our
mutual friend james altucher says he
never publishes something unless he fear
feels scared to do so and i've kind of
adopted that and you have other things
in there as in the book as well among
the same thing can you use fear as a
compass instead of courage
well it's funny how your mind works that
you're instantly going to like how do i
have a theory about this or a system um
which which makes total sense um
one of the things that i have thought
about
uh
with this is that um
you make a good point right the upside
down side ratio is really hard for
people and this is a big thing we get
wrong so we go um i'm just a little guy
right now i'm just starting out of my
career i'm newly hired i'm not tenured
what whatever you know i'm i'm uh just
put up my first book you know i'm on my
first year contract in the nfl
and we say i will be courageous later
when i'm more secure
right when i have tenure then i will
speak out when i
mark right when i have a long-term
contract when i have uh you know hit the
best seller list for the first time
after i have my kids or buy my first
house or whatever it is we after i get
reelected you know whatever um and then
this is what life does to us we never
actually do that because now
we actually uh we think that when we
have those things we'll feel secure and
that will be a base that allows us to be
courageous in fact it's a it's something
that chains us because now we're afraid
of losing that thing and you might think
well why is a billionaire uh you know
worried about losing money um
uh you know they could afford to lose it
but it's precisely because they know how
hard it was to get to a billion dollars
they don't want to risk the capital that
they just earned and i found this to be
particularly true with the politicians
that i've i've met it's like you're a
senator you're one of a hundred most
powerful people in the world effectively
um and you're like expecting somebody
else to do something about this because
all you're thinking about is like it was
so hard to become a senator i just got
here
why doesn't somebody else
put their ass on the line i have
re-election in five years or whatever
right um and so
it's it's really tricky and we we never
end up doing it and so uh
that that's the challenge that we're all
on the upside of courage can seem
relatively low uh and then the downsides
can seem very high
we have to step back and go
this is a collective action problem
right if everyone looked at the
self-preservation
uh
as as as the rubric for whether you
should do it or not
we'd of course never move forward as a
society somebody has to do it and i
think part of courage is kind of the
answer of
uh to that question from hillel uh if
not me then who if not now than when
yeah and i look at that and and you you
make this case in the as i call it the
homework problem at the end of the book
where you go through a worked example in
your own life of when you let yourself
down your future self down we'll get to
that in a bit um but um but in reality i
think there is so much kind of
gamification like we're worried about
losing followers or losing subscribers
or losing voters as you said in
politicians or not losing money but you
look at losing the nobel prize you look
at bill gates so one of the reasons that
bill gates allegedly you know held off
on his divorce announcement uh was so
that he could be nominated for the nobel
prize in the nobel peace prize and he
didn't want to compromise that because
this is reported in many other places um
so you look at that and it's like nobody
gets into the promised land you combine
that with you talk a lot about moses in
here and the the most common phrase in
the torah in the old testament as we
call it is uh is do not be afraid but i
wonder the second half of that ryan and
i know i believe you're agnostic to
atheists i know you write a lot about
christianity i i'm a practicing jew but
i learn tremendous amounts from atheists
from i read your book every day uh the
daily stoic um right so i believe we
have much to learn from from all
different traditions including none but
the second half of that sentence which i
don't think you mentioned in the book
the second house of do not be afraid
it's always a company to be with because
i am your god in other words there is a
transcendent um connected to it just
like some of the commandments that are
um uh are seem obvious like don't put a
stumbling block in front of the blind
that's a mitzvah a commandment um now
who would do that like
maybe someone in texas might do that but
we would never do that right so um no
but the second half of that commandment
is because i am god meaning that you
could get away with that you could hate
your brother in your heart you could put
a stumbling block in front of your uh a
blind friend you could not help a donkey
with its burden no one would know
because it's just you the donkey or the
blame so but the thing is can you have
courage um can you not fear if you don't
believe in god i mean a lot of my
listeners are science you know they're
they're not they don't believe in
anything so is god a predicate for for
having courage or if not how do you
transcend this um that the
transcendental i mean you might you
might argue that um it's it takes more
courage uh to do it without the belief
in a god uh than it does to do with the
belief in a god right i sort of make the
argument that the the the christians in
the stoics essentially hold very similar
tenants right the same cardinal virtues
the christians are saying follow these
virtues or you will go to hell right or
follow these virtues or or you will
incur god's wrath right and i feel like
the stoics are saying follow these
virtues or you will live in hell right
or you will experience the wrath of a
bad life of wasted potential you will i
think the stoics are making an
inherently more logical argument but
it's also demanding more of the person
to think about pascal's wager um the
uncertainty of it
is the scary part right if you if you if
you can believe without evidence if you
believe that uh
at the in the end none of it matters
because that you have the afterlife i'm
not i'm not saying that you're cowardly
that that's not what i'm saying i'm just
saying that that to wrestle with the
ambiguity and the uncertainty of it
it does strike me as a scarier
proposition
and yet in the book you you portray the
the stoic ability to use the cardinals
as a as a principle and it reminds me
you know when i take my kids to the
supermarket you have little kids now
yeah i have little kids and you go to
the supermarket the checkout line or all
the impulse purchases well they have no
impulse control right so they'll go
through it and i'll say um no you can't
have that if i say oh it's high in
calories and saturated sugar whatever
i'm not a i'm not a dietitian as you can
probably tell despite my physique uh but
if you do that it does it doesn't work
but if i say no that's not kosher then
they stop in other words
which ultimately involves this one
choice this one free will decision of
like do you believe in god and i think
that's kind of superficial like jordan
peterson says like how how hubristic is
it to say do i believe in god you know
versus what i always say is like does
god believe in me i think it is it is
fascinating to look at systems and
you've interviewed you've spoken in the
military uh you have a quote from um uh
is it mcchrystal on the cover or madison
mattis mad dog mattis uh you you're uh
in the football locker rooms your
consultant so you're in the throes of
battle although you admit you never went
to war but but it's so it's a different
type of courage but when you see that
that's a commitment to something greater
right one nation under god or like
people but we there's a reason we sing
the national anthem as god um so yeah so
i think i think that this is an
interesting alternative to not have god
but it's not anti-god in other words you
can believe in god and and these virtues
are in sympathy and it made me think
ryan what would what would seneca or or
you know what would um uh what would
that titus say you know if they were
alive today would they be verified on
twitter in other words if they could see
what martin luther king's courage looked
like as you portray or what florence
nightingale or what um or what frederick
douglass did as you lovingly and
accurately portray what would they make
of the people that came after them that
are sort of imbuing some of their
intellectual dna or their their stoic
dna how would they react to what what
has come after them i mean we don't we
don't know but i would hope that they
would see in the in the way that's like
you sort of understand your grandparents
ha saw the world a certain way have a
certain set of beliefs and then
you flash forward to the present you're
like i really hope i really hope they
they can transcend the limitations of
their time and not be awful right like
to to get past this and and so i think
with the stoics it's like with thomas
jefferson but the beauty of and the
paradox of thomas jefferson is he writes
down this beautiful idea uh that that
all men are created equal but he clearly
doesn't mean it right or he struggles to
actually make good on those words and
then uh both to his credit and his shame
uh every subsequent generation has moved
us a tiny bit closer to the literal
truth of those words abraham lincoln
does a great job theodore uh
frederick douglass does a great job
martin luther king does a
spectacular job of of moving us a little
bit closer to that now one would hope
thomas jefferson when shown the evidence
uh would would
be encouraged and inspired by the
extension of the logic
but we don't know right we don't know um
so i i would hope that you know marcus
aurelius and epictetus and seneca who
were
very much products of their time but
also progressive and forward thinking
for their time
would be able to appreciate the
extrapolation and the extension
of the rules that they laid down
but i think we have to be in a place
where we're fine uh if they don't like
seneca talking about epicurus who he
disagrees with on essentially everything
says i will quote a bad author if the
line is good so even if you could give
me
incontrovertible proof that marcus
aurelius was
worse of a hypocrite than thomas
jefferson and certainly there's a lot of
evidence that seneca sucked right i mean
seneca is nero's tutor and right-handed
yeah um
you you would still not have to throw
the baby out with the bath water right
you might be disgusted by it but you
don't have to discard everything
i would just say what i love about the
stokes is it does feel like they were
largely consistent with the ideas under
pretty real pressure they had real skin
in the game but i'm i guess i would be
it would be painful but i'd like to
think i could i could separate the two
yeah and i think you do and it's always
dangerous to encounter factual history
as of course but you mentioned thomas uh
jefferson and and also in your
conversation with tom bilyeu um about
this book a couple weeks ago and it made
me think you know thomas jefferson was
deeply influenced by by euclid you know
the ancient greeks in fact the first
lines of the of the declaration of
impact we hold these truths to be
self-evident those lines come directly
from euclid where he would say two line
parallel lines never meet and we don't
even have to prove it it's self-evident
of course they don't meet on on a curved
space time like we might live in uh or
on the earth's surface something or in a
pringles universe if we lived on a
pringle chip um so some things that seem
self-evident aren't necessarily so but i
think it is complicated and and you do
go through in very uh i would say tender
almost and and very thorough these great
people great men great women have great
flaws they often have great flaws and to
require that they be perfect or we don't
follow them i i think it's it's
ludicrous and
that for that reason i want to go to not
not the worked example that you use in
the book which is where you talk about
your time at american apparel and this
real crisis of of conscience that you
faced and and you handled it as you as
you recount um and and maybe you can
quickly summarize the story but i i
don't like to give away the book for
free so you should feel free
but i was i was uh curious because you
were uh if i recall you were in the
university of california system for a
while
our sister to the north yep and
riverside and uh and and and yet you
dropped out and i want to talk about
that was there was there an element to
that as a worked example a lot of my
audience are academics and we face this
kind of academic hunger games where you
have to get a good grades in high school
to go to college to college go to grad
school grad school get a postdoc postdoc
professor tenner
it's the whole hunger games it's all the
gamification um
what courage did that because you were
much younger than you were at 23 at
american apparel
some of that um you know kind of uh the
the the courage muscle that you built up
in that decision did that lead to
further down the line on american
apparel which wasn't perfect but who is
yeah um and then uh you know uh and then
later on into what you did later as you
talk about the new york observer et
cetera so take us back to that decision
to drop out of call not that i'm
encouraging my students
me neither
no i i so at 19 when i dropped out or 20
when i dropped out i forget exactly um
because i came from a stable normal sort
of middle class home um that was
unquestionably the scariest thing that i
had ever done in my life um i was on a
scholarship uh i was in the honors
program i was on track to graduate in
three years and i'd already finished two
right so like college i wasn't failing
out of college the way that some people
did and it also wasn't like a mark
zuckerberg or a bill gates situation
where i was like i'd already started a
successful company and this was like
holding me back this was you know the
opportunity to go study under a writer
and have like a real nine to five job
or stay in college stay in the bubble uh
get the the resume sort of safety net uh
or or not right and two things made it
uh one thing made it a lot harder and
another thing made it a lot easier
actually a couple one my girlfriend at
the time my now wife was incredibly
supportive uh and said of course you
should do it this is a
once-in-a-lifetime thing and i had some
mentors who said the same thing now my
parents on the other hand uh said you
cannot do this you will not just you
cannot do this we don't want you to do
it but like
we
think you will fail you uh have let us
down uh and by the way uh we're shutting
off your cell phone uh you know you owe
us this amount of money for your tuition
and your car and
all these things right so it was like it
was it wasn't just like hey i'm thinking
about doing this thing there's no
consequence it was it was like no no you
have to pay the consequences up front
right um
so that all made it much much scarier
and again as a 19 year old you're you're
like uh
a leaf you know you can get blown in
either direction um
but i ended up sort of deciding to do it
it was terrifying and i remember i
walked into the registrar's office
and i was like i'm here to drop out of
college uh i think it was hinder haker
hall or whatever there's like one of
those on every uc campus right um uh so
i walked in and i was like i'm here to
drop out you know i said this to the
little lady at the at the booth and she
was like
that's not a thing
right she's like there's no form for
that she was like you can take a
semester off right like you can
disenroll from the upcoming semester um
but that's like as far as this like she
was like
now look by doing this you give up your
scholarship right like the scholarship
is con so so that was an irrevocable
part of it but um she was like you're
taking you're disenrolling for this
semester and then you have 10 years to
re-enroll at any time and so it was
funny because i just spent like a week
tearing my my hair out i was terrified i
was convinced that i was if this didn't
work i would live under a bridge
somewhere you know that i've been
disowned and brought shame to my family
and then you sort of get there in the
moment and they're like
no this is like a
paperwork issue you know like you could
come back at any time and so that that
was a big breakthrough for me because
you just realize a lot of the things
that you assume are permanent that you
assume you assume are uh uh
life-changing um and incredibly risky
are in fact much smaller and much more
of a paperwork issue
than you might have been informed of
yeah and i you know the famous quote you
know little kids little problems big
kids big problems but if you normalize
them you know to the to the size or the
age of the person like your your
five-year-old or whatever getting
bullied at school is like you getting
you know facing your parents cutting off
your cell phone bill or are you getting
far now i think it's ironic because i do
see you as an educator i mean if i had
to say you're not just a writer you're a
teacher and you know of course in the
gamified world of academia you know it's
pretty hard to become a professor
without that but is there anything about
the academic life that that you miss or
that you could see coming back to not
not to go back to finish your degree
it's like yeah mark mark zuckerberg
could have been something if he got that
harvard degree right it's a joke
i love that and i do i do think about
that because it was funny as soon as i
left um and then i decided i started
like working on my first book i
started going back because i lived in
los angeles at the time i would go back
to the riverside
library on campus and that's where i did
most of the research for my first book
and then i wrote my second book or my
first book at the tulane library in new
orleans so there's something very sort
of special and nostalgic for me about
like college campuses and college
libraries i wrote a good chunk of ego is
the enemy at the university of texas
library um as my books became more
successful i sort of was able to
cultivate a space of my own that that
was easier and just involved less sort
of commute but um there's something
about the space that was really
important to me um and and the the vibe
and the the the mood um so
uh very much so um and look if you told
me uh hey you know this university wants
to have you as a visiting professor of x
y or z i i i think it's almost the thing
that you spurn in life becomes sort of
disproportionately valuable to you um so
like in a weird way um that would
probably mean as much or more to me as
some of the stuff i've been able to do
on my own so i have like and when when
kids come to me and they're like hey i'm
thinking about dropping out of college
i'm like you know what like i don't want
any part of this like that was i went
through that once uh and it was the
scariest thing i ever did like i'm not
going to convince you one way or another
you got to figure this out on your own
because i i really don't have
like a grudge against higher education
the way i think some dropouts do
because it did work for me in the sense
that it got me to where i
took an off-ramp
but like uh
i don't think that would have been
possible without there and and had uh
had i not had that opportunity i just
would have continued
yeah i want to talk about that in the
context of uh another advocate although
he didn't employ this uh but subject of
your book peter thiel who i've met on
occasion through our mutual friend eric
weinstein and uh you know and peter of
course is an advocate for kind of the
the uh not not the debunking but maybe
uh non-traditional approach to college
even coming up with scholarships against
it uh but the reason i wanna talk about
peter is because he makes an appearance
in this book
uh again as he did in conspiracy which
is just a a wonderful a wonderful read
it's it's like it's it's it's like it is
a true crime story i guess yeah and at
such high stakes but the reason i want
to talk about it is not necessarily to
talk about peter specifically but just
this this that peter appears in a book
about a stoic a virtue series sure and
and that you have this stoic brand and
yet i i also know that you have many
other ability skills you're a podcaster
you do and it's not all stoic but i
wonder do you ever worry and this is
said with complete and utter respect and
fascination but i mean do you worry
about getting typecast as like only like
stoic and you know i you do think you
did conspiracy specifically and that's
not a stoic virtue book but sure do you
ever worry about that ryan as like
enough with the stoicism as you know as
jerry costanzo might say or
i i mean i don't think so much about
being typecast but i i do um
i do sometimes worry that
the cumulative impact or
value of the philosophy gets sort of
disproportionately credited to me which
is uncomfortable i see myself as someone
who's a student of and writing about the
philosophy um not in any way
like a
master of it but also uh a a creator of
it so it's it's maybe like uh i don't
know like uh
somebody who's really associated with a
certain subject because they've spent a
long time as their biographer
um you're sort of basking in the
reflexive glory of that even though
you're
you have much more of a workmanlike
relationship with it um so so that
that's kind of a weird thing um
and and i mean i appreciate the benefits
of it i'm just also aware of sort of the
like i have a little um i have a little
piece of paper here that i wrote down um
that i just said am i being a good
steward of stoicism meaning that um
it's not mine i didn't make it up i have
no right to it but for whatever reason
i'm in a position of sort of leadership
or identified as a leader in a specific
space and i feel like that comes with a
certain set of obligations and
responsibilities that i do try to be
cognizant of that perhaps i wouldn't if
i wrote about you know
something else if i just wrote political
thrillers or something i wouldn't feel
like i was a a steward of american
democracy that would be strange
and also i've seen on your channel
you've done a like a home tour a book
yeah a bookshop tour and and you have
these almost obsessive amounts of
reminders of death memento mori you've
got coins you've got uh paintings of you
know someone shooting an arrow at you um
yeah there it is yeah i you inspired me
to brand i want to make my own meteorite
cosmic dust uh coins that's a great idea
yeah um but um but you know these guys
lived in the time you talked about this
a little bit on your podcast with the
woman a professor from duke today on
daley stoick i think yesterday you know
they lived in a time when death was a
real i mean most women died in
childbirth
it took great courage to to like go out
in the streets there was no uh police
you know presence
and they live with constant fear of it
are we just kind of you know like
substituting the dopamine hit that you
might feel or or the adrenaline hit that
you might feel uh by this constant
specter of death and and i felt like be
careful what you wish for like you know
the obsession with death uh sure is that
that's like i think anything taken too
far can become unhealthy but it does
strike me as like okay in
in the middle ages one of the most
dangerous times to ever be alive
they're still having to practice memento
mori so like death is literally ever
present you're walking down the street
and there's just putrid dead bodies in
in the gutter and they're like don't
forget death you could die so it to me
that says something about how
insidious our mind is as far as pushing
things that are uncomfortable or
unpleasant out of the forefront so it's
like if they had to practice the art of
momentum or in the whole uh you know
genre of memento mori dance macabre uh
vanitas the reminder of the ephemerality
of life i mean this is like
thousands of years old and pervasive
throughout you know the the the ancient
world if they had to do it then
we definitely have to do it now when
life expectancy is 80 infant mortality
is low
and even when you do die you die in a
hospital bed removed from you know
witnesses or
you know uh like
i've maybe seen i know i know i have but
like i would say your average person in
the u.s has probably never seen a dead
body before and if they have it was
almost certainly at a funeral right like
just the
you just think about how
i mean not only were like people dying
of of unju like you know executions and
murders and stuff and let's say rome but
then they would like display the bodies
like
as as like deterrence or you know
political state i mean you would have
you it might have been a strange day
that you didn't see a dead body right
and so if they had to still then
write as seneca does over and over again
about you know keeping death in mind i
suspect we have to do it even more now
not not to an unhealthy degree but to
some degree that we're not in denial
about it
yeah and on one of your uh videos uh
tours you know you kind of talk about
this this myth that you you know like
you just got to get through as many
books as possible and and you know how
many books have you read on your
bookshelf and obviously you've read all
these books in in many cases 100 times
each um but i wonder you know you often
say like it's not like how many books
you move off your list but how the books
move you but i wonder you know should
there be a memento vivi or something
like because we do live better than than
nero did you know the poorest person in
america in the third world in the first
world uh lives better and and you've
been around the world you've traveled
around the world we live so well
is it that we need to be reminded that
we're gonna die or that we're not really
living because it seems to me the
purpose of not life is not just to live
it and that goes back to the risk
discussion we had earlier
yeah i i think that
that might be the same way of of saying
what i'm saying or they might be trying
to get you to the same place which is um
uh first off some people just tremble at
the thought of death and this makes them
very conservative and reluctant to live
other people are in denial and so they
act as if they have unlimited time right
yeah not in the backyard ernest becker
book yeah we we we act as if uh seneca
says we act as mortals in all that we
fear and immortals in all that we desire
right so we want and want and want as if
we can take the money with us forever as
if we get to experience our fame or what
renowned or pleasure forever so to me
memento mori is really just about
uh presents i'll give you an example so
uh this
marcus aurelius quoting epictetus uh and
i thought about this a lot during the
pandemic he says as you tuck your child
into bed at night say to yourself they
may not survive until morning i do that
now thanks to you
i cannot do it though my wife cannot do
it it i mean it goes against every
instinct you have as a parent i would
say probably as a mother even more so um
but uh
the purpose of that is not detachment
it's not like
uh now if i wake up and something
horrible has happened overnight i'm like
cool right that's it's the opposite of
that marcus aurelius not only loses uh
some children in infancy but there's a
few haunting lines in meditations where
you get the sense that he is
deeply pained uh and mourning this fact
he talks about he says like it's
foolishness uh to to expect bad people
not to do bad things and then he says
and and to reach for children who are no
longer there right he's got this sense
of like he's mourning this these these
children that he lost that he loved to
me the purpose of your child might not
make it to the morning is
uh to go sure i'll read you one more
book like you know sure uh you you need
me to go get you water or like sure you
don't want me to leave or you know what
like it's to say
i don't need to go check my email like
forget netflix you know um
uh yeah i wanted to go for a bike ride
before the sun went down but that's not
how it's shaking out tonight
so
what like i this is also great you know
what i mean and so to me memento mori is
a reminder to live it's not memento mori
life is meaningless uh memento mori be
afraid it is memento mori uh don't waste
this
well that's a very lovely way to
characterize it okay i want to take a
little break from the seriousness of it
and uh and step back a little bit if you
uh will indulge me with your forbearance
which is which is probably the fifth uh
virtue that that we'll add on we'll
start contributing if we can construct
uh a four-dimensional cardinal
that would be pretty cool i would say
forbearance is in
so so this is actually something i've
been thinking about because originally
in the in the the galley i had endurance
as part of courage which is where the
stoics typically put it i moved it to
temperance which i am
uh re
positioning slightly as self-discipline
um so forbearance to me is a virtue of
self-discipline because you you want not
to have to put up with it but you force
yourself to
uh so i'm not vain i want to
talk about something that doesn't get
enough forbearance and that is you know
kind of this this double-edged sword of
platforms of of blue check marks of the
social media of youtube channels you've
got a massive following uh that you've
earned you're completely self-made
person which is very rare by the way and
and and i look at that and and i say
well you know there's a famous story you
should probably know from animal farm
george orwell's famous book and uh
there's conversation between the pig and
benjamin the donkey and the pig says to
benjamin my what a fine tail you have i
just have this little tiny curly thing
but you have this wonderful tail and
benjamin says yeah the good lord gave me
the tail to swat away the flies but i'd
rather not have the flies and not need
the tail sure what does that mean
i mean your platform has grown
exponentially i may continue to do so if
that's if that's up your alley what do
you make of of this kind of gilded you
know uh the jail cell or garden that
we're in handcuffed velvet handcuffs you
know we're kind of beholden to these
algorithms etc sure
do you do you in some sense is the stoic
way i mean can you imagine you know uh
rufus or or you know marcus are really
really caring about how many followers
or if they get a blue check mark or not
or if they hit the best seller once god
forbid if they hit the i mean do they
care well marcus aurelius hit the best
seller list a couple years ago uh when
his meditations was retranslated and it
is funny to think about what he would
think about um finally had a good career
so to correct you slightly i would not
say that i am self-made i think uh i
would very much disagree with that um i
would say that i am independent right so
like my platform is not dependent
on a brand like say the new york times
or a university or whatever but i am uh
both not self-made in the sense that you
know i had certain advantages in life
but also not self-made in that like
even as is an independent creator i am
still as you said
subjected to the whims of the various
algorithms i try to be as independent as
possible as co-direct as possible so for
even for this launch um as you know when
you put out a book
you try to sell as many copies as
possible through the various retailers
because this is what the the best seller
lists count um i decided not to do that
i decided to sell the copies uh or a
good chunk of the copies
directly and so for this launch
i was the number one retailer of my
books more than i so more copies direct
than to amazon which is great from a
financial standpoint it's great from a
relationship standpoint um it means that
i do not appear this week on the wall
street journalists sort of mysteriously
appeared on the on the new york times
that makes two of us
i'd written off the idea that i'd hit
any of the list the new york times was
sort of a nice surprise but the point is
um we are all sort of at the whims of
these different things and people decide
you use the word gamification you decide
what game you're going to play and i i
think the stoics would like that uh that
expression play stupid games win stupid
prizes um if you if you are chasing
these sort of silly external things
whether it's the check mark or followers
or the new york times list perhaps you
will get them and then you immediately
realize that they are not worth that
much um ultimately um
i use the platforms to spread the ideas
but i understand that the uh that the
ownership of the the things are tenuous
at best um not only like from a legal
perspective like facebook owns the fans
they kick you out the platform anytime
they want um but you
while you have access to them i feel
like you try to use that as much as
possible i i have i have found it
interesting especially during the
pandemic and then this sort of civil uh
rights moment we're in
i have found it both
interesting and somewhat depressing to
see the number of people
that i know with very large platforms
who are just reluctant to
get involved or say what they really
think and these might be the very same
people who would look at a politician
and go
why aren't they doing something why are
they so cowardly why aren't you know and
then it's like you have a million
instagram followers and you don't want
to touch x y or z
because you know 22 of your audience is
x y or z and you don't want to lose them
so my philosophy has been
not to think about it just to say what i
think is important or say what i think
needs to be heard
and then the only way i protect myself
from that is i don't
check the numbers so i can rest
comfortably in the ignorance of what it
has cost me
right
yes and it can also you know just again
be this is velvet velvet gilded uh
cage that's a great way to describe it
it's
i would say the other thing is it's a
treadmill right because
you have to feed this beast right you're
like uh you want it always to be growing
you want things to be going viral and
suddenly like with money or whatever
else you're not comparing yourself to
where you were or to the average person
you're comparing yourself to
so and so i was i was just um
on instagram and i saw a friend sold
their apartment for like millions of
dollars and i was like [ __ ] uh you know
like uh i didn't know that's the level
uh that that was happening right and
then you can see how quickly your mind
is like well should i have that you know
am i am i not doing enough am i not good
enough you know am i less than this
person and and so i think all these
platforms exploit that in us
yeah and you talked about in your in an
interview i think with uh with maybe it
was tom but you mentioned you know that
you you tell people oh i have a
bookstore now and it's like every book
nerds dream you know and like here he is
he's doing it and and guess what it was
super freaking hard and it almost didn't
happen and it cost you probably more
than you planned and there was a
pandemic and the pipes burst and
everything awful that could possibly go
wrong did go wrong and yet you're you're
now you're sitting now you have made it
and so yeah again i don't want to push
back on you saying that you're not a
self-made man i i always say i'm a
self-made man but and i also worship my
own creator um okay so ryan again i
don't ask too much of your time thank
you for your forbearance um so the last
thing i want to say just maybe it's a
little frivolous but um if you could
take away courage from certain people if
you had that power
who would you take away it from uh it
seems to me you know isis had a lot of
courage you know sure a lot of bad
people have cur like what would you do
with that power that non-existent power
but um would you use it to or maybe say
it like this would you sure rather use
it to give more people more courage or
take courage away from people that don't
deserve it yeah that's a really
interesting way to think about it i've
never thought about it yeah like it
would be wonderful if vladimir putin was
a tad more timid uh right um it would be
wonderful if the strong men of uh of
history were a little less brave um that
would be great uh
i think so taking away some courage
there might be great i'd love to give i
i feel like there are certainly i was
just reading about the um
i'm and so instead of mispronouncing it
i'll just say who she was i was
fascinated by this hungarian woman who
immigrated to the united states who was
sort of the backbone of the for for many
many uh unrecognized years of of
mrna uh uh research basically uh it's a
catalan something but but anyways she's
the professor whose research is
essentially the backbone of the covid
vaccine uh and and
as you said uh about the prizes get
snubbed for a nobel this year um you
know only only saves uh like a billion
or so lives but um you know why should
that be recognized but um you know
there was a new york times piece about
her
and there was someone like the author or
a quote or whatever at the end goes like
you know she's not the only one like
this she basically soldiers on in the
basement of the ivory tower for years
and years and years always fighting for
funding her bosses would get promoted or
poached and then she'd have to fight for
a job fight to keep uh you know her
think her her husband manages an
apartment complex for a living she never
makes more than 60 000 a year um but
after 30 years that research changes the
world right and she knew
she knew every day uh you know she was
like her husband was like don't feel too
sorry for her she was excited to go to
work every day right right um and so i
would i know there are lots of people
out there doing that kind of work
that don't have that courage or
confidence
it would be wonderful and i think the
world would be profoundly changed if
those people
you know if you could sprinkle some of
that fairy dust onto them
all right ryan we have reached the end
of the uh normal segment and now if you
will indulge me i will do you in the
impossible so these are three questions
i ask all my guests uh from billionaires
to brainiacs and ryan you're both of
those now
and uh ten nobel prize winners to date
uh on this podcast that have honored me
by coming up first one has to do with
your near-term legacy and it's a concept
in hebrew we call the ethical will or
zava the first one came from jacob when
he gathers his sons and it's for
non-jews and it's for non-sons it's for
anybody right um so it's what kind of
wisdom or teaching or ideology not just
stoicism obviously play a role in it but
what component would you put in an
ideological will not not not a material
well for your ideological errors of
which i count myself as one
that's a great question i mean i think
it's the four virtues are sort of would
be at the top of that list um i i when
when people ask me this question this
question what would you put on a
billboard it sometimes reminds me it
humbles me in the sense that like
i am not
an original thinker so much as i am a
communicator or a
popularizer and so i would invariably
use something like this to popularize
something that someone else uh said so
it might seem weird that i would want my
legacy to be something that's already
you know very well established in the
in the material or sorry in the in the
uh
in the christian and the philosophical
worlds but uh there's a marx surrealist
quote he says the fruit of this life is
good character and acts for the common
good and i feel like that is a really
good imperative uh for like
what we should be striving for as human
beings
yeah there's a youtuber in the uk named
ali abdal who worships you he's a writer
he always talks about you and he yeah he
talks exactly from that phrase which i'm
sure he got from you you know what is
the meaning of life is basically to do
as much good as possible and whatever
time you have so i think that's
beautiful um next question goes a little
bit deeper into the future not to the
biblical age of 120 when you spring
forth this mortal coil as moses uh did
but i want to ask you um you might know
the book by arthur c clarke the sentinel
which became uh the 2001 space odyssey
script essentially and there are these
monoliths there are these like kind of
ominous a little bit frightening but
maybe harmless we don't know what they
are they're kind of like
time capsules perhaps planted by an
alien civilization for us to discover
when we're ready in the beginning they
appear on the serengeti planes some
hominins hitting it with a bone and then
later they're on the moon um i want to
ask you ryan if you had a billion year
lasting time capsule uh what would you
put on it or in it uh you know don't
make it like a usb key because yeah who
knows that they'll be able to read that
it'll be like betamax but what would you
put to last to caps encapsulate what
greatness human uh accomplishment has
wrought
oh that's really great um
i don't know you know some someone once
described marcus aurelius's meditations
as the highest ethical product of the
ancient mind
and it's i think there's something
you know all books including my books
are written for an audience right so
almost all philosophy
was written with an audience in mind
even epictetus even nicomancian ethics
these are like lecture notes from a
professor speaking to an audience so
inherently
a public facing
philosophy and what i think is so
profoundly amazing and irreplicable
about meditations is that it is a work
of philosophy intended for the self he
would be mortified you know that we're
reading it today probably i i would make
up because it's clearly not written for
that there's notes to the self there's
weird illusions that no one would
possibly understand
there's a lot of repetition
but the specificity of it becomes its
universality
and
i think it would be pretty magical
uh to
for to know that that piece of work
survived another thousand years i mean
that it stood up for for 2000 is a
pretty good run but if you were like hey
you know if you did x uh you could add a
thousand years to that although to the
lindy effect maybe that's already
happening um but but but but it'd be
something like that
yeah it's funny because i remember one
of the first things you said to me when
we met four years ago virtually you said
you know you know what your books
competing against and i was like all
these science popularizations and nobel
prize take downs you said no every
freaking cat video on youtube yeah every
other way that people have to not read
your freaking book and that really you
know hit home with me and i do try to
keep that in mind nobody has to read our
books but they do and uh maybe i'll take
a 2a question okay and ask you would you
rather have you know millions of readers
a year from now or now or like one
reader a hundred years from now
that's a good question i mean i guess it
depends on what you're optimizing for
you know the stoics sort of talk about
how uh you're not around to enjoy your
posthumous fame so it's not it's not
worth that much
um
i get i think maybe i would pivot and go
is that reading
popularity like is it is it are you
telling me i guess i would if you're out
to me the more interesting question is
uh
is uh would you trade it profoundly
changing one person or being popular
with but having relatively little impact
with lots of people and i would probably
choose choose the profound impact be a
bad financial choice but but probably
the uh the philosophical choice it's
funny about half the authors i've asked
had uh have said either one you know in
other words so they half want the money
now and then there's there's there to be
commended for that the stoics weren't
averse to wealth as you talk about um
and maybe one day you'll do the you know
stoics guide to investing uh but the
other half want to have an impact right
and some of the impact is is just if it
affects the one person which you should
remember as you say okay last question
goes back in time the first the only
question that goes back in time and it's
related to the namesake of this podcast
sir arthur c clarke whose first law was
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic and i open
the show with that phrase every week
and the second law is for every expert
there's an equal and opposite expert but
the third law is the only way of
discovering the limits of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible so that's the name
of this podcast into the impossible i
want to ask you going backwards in time
advice to your former self essentially
what piece of advice would you give
yourself and i've always asked this of
every author not just those who have the
word courage in their book title but i
said what would you give advice to give
yourself to give you the courage to go
into the impossible
um
i would i would tell myself to relax i
took everything way too seriously so i
was wound very tight
um and i think that made it harder to do
uh what was like in in the story that i
tell at the end of the book um i just
over thought it um i had uh alexander
vinman on the podcast recently yeah um
the whistleblower and he has this great
line in the book where he talks about um
self-deterring you know he how we did he
says we self-deter right we do this on
foreign policy it's not that we're
actually intimidated by the the the
enemy we just overthink it and we get
too much in our own heads about it um
like i should have just done what i
thought was right you know i should have
said i don't or or just all the things
that i've said yes to in my life that i
didn't need to do i should have just
said
uh no you know i i think i think if i
could have relaxed a little bit more
been a tad less concerned about the
future and just trusted myself a bit
more had a bit more confidence
i feel like some of my decisions in the
past would have aged better
very well well ryan i speak on behalf of
the vast audience of apostles of ryan
holiday celebrate the ryan holiday i
want to thank you so much for doing all
that you've done to benefit me
personally professionally and i speak
for millions of people around the world
ryan holiday thank you so much for going
into the impossible awesome you're the
best man i appreciate it
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you